[Music]
obviously this is a team that's
notoriously been called chokers in a
developmental fortitude but it just
keeps happening right it's always in the
semifinals there's got to be this mental
block but it's so weird because even
it's not it's not even like apparent to
themselves you know the look on device's
face he's had a shocker of a game to
finish things off there the major 16
plays five it's a disappointing way to
end it
[Music]
yeah it's quite a historic moment right
yeah
astralis not making into the legend
status and obviously north dropping out
as well and
questions of whether this team will stay
around
[Music]
they just joined the roster a few months
ago bring more firepower to the squad
he's certainly done that and all under
magisk now in the 1v2 the bomb now down
as well for phase and oh my god matches
i don't know who can challenge them
anymore this is just a look for some
people it's a problem for others
it's basking in the greatness that can't
possibly be real
they're the best team in counter-strike
history in my opinion this is the most
competitive era it doesn't matter none
of these teams can match astralis to
take down alex another push
untouchable
undisputed
season seven
chicago
and now for the first time ever at home
season eight i've strolled into the
champions of anthem
and for the first time in history the
best of all time
for years before cs go's release the
danish counter-strike scene was rightly
revered as one of the titans of 1.6
competition players like trace zonic and
sunday built a legacy of cs excellence
but when global offensive released
denmark took a while to find its footing
and the world waited to see when or
maybe if danish teams would again return
to the podium consistently in december
of 2015 it looked like denmark might
actually get their answer after team
solomid's entire cs go roster decided to
simultaneously quit and form their own
independent team device dupree zipix
cajunbee and kerrigan along with team
dignitas zonic as coach came together
under the banner of team question mark a
placeholder organization that would
later be converted into astralis in
january of 2016. device and dupreeh had
played together since 2013 while sonic's
time as a 1.6 pro left him well equipped
for the struggles to come the exact
details of what led to the split have
never been fully ironed out both sides
famously stated different reasons for
the split what's abundantly clear
however was that tsm wanted to run the
team one way and the players wanted to
run it differently we we wanted to see
if our own organization could match
what we could get from other
organizations and it basically could it
makes more
it makes more meaning for us to play
under astralis now than it would be to
play on another brand once the deans
were able to form the team they dreamed
of astralis first year showed flashes of
promise that said despite having an
incredibly talented roster with great
chemistry on paper astralis had a
problem they couldn't stop choking at
high level events and now zip nicks with
it all on his shoulders or it's gonna be
fanatic through to those finals bomb is
planted and zipnicks now walking in
catches out flusher gets pressured from
jw and there it is fnatic get out of
those semis and get themselves into the
finals astralis
sadly floundering under a fanatic
brought into this game and by joking we
mean really joking time and time again
astralis would take it to perennial
powerhouses like sk gaming or nip until
suddenly sometimes after a pause was
called or the map changed the team's
luck would flatline i know the
astronauts guys pretty well like couple
of them are good friends of mine i'm not
even sure if they're completely clued up
on
the reasons why
what happens happens you've talked to
device many times right it's like if you
ask them like i've interviewed kerrigan
as well and asked them specifically
about it they hate talking about it
they're calling it choking right
but it just keeps happening right it's
always at the semi-finals it's gotta be
this mental block but it's so weird
because even it's not it's not even like
apparent to themselves you know this
phenomenon which haunted them throughout
the course of 2016 would come to be
known as the astralis curse that's cajun
as well gonna fall and i dare say it
it's over navier in the grand final the
second straight time just to reiterate
astralis
looking some of the best form we've ever
seen the men coming into this final
semi-final but at esl one cologne in
july the year's final major they were
facing much more than just a curse aside
from general nerves astralis was dealing
with a roster shakeup kirby who joined
the team only a few weeks prior after
being traded by dignitas for cajun b
wasn't able to play and neither could
dupree after coming down with
appendicitis astralis called on glaive
one of device's childhood best friends
and sonic the team's coach to fill the
two spots respectively definitely not
ideal this is a horrible situation you
feel like astrology can't get a break
right now everything they turn up to it
seems like there's something that goes
horribly wrong when they do well in the
groups their counterparts just fall
apart and they actually have a horrible
run to the actual playoffs but today is
a very special occasion the fact that
we're missing dupree as well when
they're star players shout out to peter
we love you great personality in the
scene hope you're getting better but
this is a massive loss for them going
into this one despite being down two of
their core players astralis fought
fiercely to get to the quarterfinals
where they played virtus pro at times
looking like they had what it took to
make a run at the title
it's gonna be a tough retake they do
have to get on tas but it's sonic again
joined by glaive glade with three
already
this is beautiful work from astralis
keeping four up and kerrigan closes out
astralis kick this one off with a bang
already a bomb plant a hell of a lot of
kills as well to boot they're 15 seconds
sonic's found him it's down to snacks in
the 1v2 here this could be australis
going 13-13
they might just be lucky for australis
at this point here we go stacks goes
down there's clay for the kill and
astralis are back in this game
and what looked like a disastrous start
has turned into something incredible
astralis will not go down without a
fight zipmix gets that first kill and
just falls back and fakes him right into
the crosshair of the vice this is
beautifully done a second kill it's all
down to neo and he gets nothing 11-4 for
astralis
this is a masterful first half coming
through here from astralis these guys
are looking exceedingly solid here but
even with their best efforts better
still than most expected astralis
couldn't stop what seemed at this point
inevitable there's snacks coming in with
one of his left siblings
in a horrible situation bialy's already
on the hunt and you can see them looking
for it and the spray comes in ziplex
knows his days are numbered but he's
still fighting the good fight but if
that's the end pascha does it for
brothers pro and ladies and gentlemen
that is vp putting themselves into the
semi-finals
after a tough match against the straws
who fought with sheer heart great
determination anything you could think
of they put it up there i think that
today we should talk about different
team
we should talk about astralis and
how much resilience they showed
playing with two standings
i think that we should all clap for them
now guys
[Applause]
neither 2016 major went the way astralis
had wanted but the second major at
cologne had at least offered somewhat of
a glimmer of hope and with that astralis
decided they needed to reorganize in
october of that year kerrigan left for
phase which gave astralis the chance to
sign glaive for real with the vice a
multi-talented monster of a player and
glaive becoming one of csgo's best
up-and-coming igls at the helm astralis
seemed to have its strongest roster yet
but they still needed to get their
mentality right the pressure of being on
stage of competing in front of so many
people and trying to prove that they
belonged among the game's best was
clearly affecting astralis ability to
perform at the highest level so
management decided to try something
practically unheard of in esports at
that time the organization which was
quickly becoming a well-oiled machine
compared to the traditional bunch of
friends on stage cs powerhouses hired a
sports psychologist i have said that
while glaive has been important the
introduction of a sports psychologist
for australis also very important with
their history of choking team australis
is a dream client for me
first we started off working with the
team spirit then of course i do
individual work with them because all of
them have their strengths and weaknesses
as players
it's always day by day you kind of like
see in what kind of shape the boys are
in how they're doing they're constantly
developing so you have to
keep adapting to that as well so it's
all days are different with a more
holistic approach to the physical and
mental health of its players astralis
began to excel rapidly winning first at
ecs season 2 in december of 2016 and
then after a legacy of disappointments
on the major stage they finally did it
it's the team that struggled in groups
but showed true form against liquid
they've never looked stronger since
adding glaive
this is astralis
obviously this is a team that's
notoriously been called chokers and they
don't have that mental fortitude do you
think on that evidence we're seeing a
change there they either lose very very
narrowly or they smash people yeah so
astralis pretty much they're on a course
to go to the final and so if you're a
fanatic you can say yeah maybe they can
choke but you have to be able to put
them in that position before that can
even happen device alone kirby's not
there he's got the high hp but he hasn't
up he's missed shots that could have
crossed him it does what a shot from
crims fanatic in the most magical way or
pulling it back but look at kirby right
time right place astralis overcoming all
odds and the curse that has always been
their problem it's crims down it's one
to go it's only dennis remaining
desperate with a bomb and 15 hp caught
out blinded up and here he's got him
for the first time
for the danish side they'll find
themselves in a major final
and that is a huge huge relief but
they're not done these guys mean
business they knew coming into this
tournament they had one goal they're the
favorites for a reason one versus two he
has to clutch this australis mentally
they need this to get back into the game
he sees the gun barrel headshot on one
now comes pasha next in line dupree
going forward doing the damage and he
gets it one versus two this is
incredible are we going to see it are
straw is going to break the curse are
they going to win their first major the
first time they're in the finals and
their first title will find out because
the action's on and gary opens it up
takes down bialy already
here's the start four more kills and
they will have made it the full distance
snacks in an uncomfortable position he
goes down with the max 70 car make it
happen finally pasha coming in with a
refract but he's down the bomb has been
picked up by the three they get the
spray neo takes one and turns it down
major championship 16-14
unbelievable
for the first time ever astralis had won
a major and not just that but their
final is considered one of the greatest
cs matches ever played despite the win
including another first place win over
phase at iem katowice astralis slowly
fell into old habits throughout the rest
of the year astralis resumed its routine
of placing anywhere from seventh to
second place at every competition on the
board in november device revealed that
he had a hiatal hernia and would be on
medical leave for at least a month for
all intents and purposes astralis was
done for 2017. yet device was still
looking forwards motivated by his
medical leave device pushed to have even
more self-care amenities provided to the
players including personal trainers and
chefs to keep them both physically and
mentally healthy the final piece of the
puzzle came when kirby unexpectedly and
without announcement left astralis to
join north in february of 2018 something
that teammates like device felt was a
bit of a betrayal so yeah it's a bit sad
but
i hope that he does well and when i see
him at events we say hi and i still feel
like we can get a good relationship out
of it but
it's just yeah it's just sad to feel
betrayed in some way regardless of how
hurt they were by his sudden departure
astralis needed a replacement for kierby
and in a surprise move named magisk as
their new fifth this officially marked
the beginning of a new era for the team
what they chokingly called astralis 2.0
and at that moment they assembled a
lineup of the five danes that would go
on to become counter-strike deities this
new astralis took 2018 by storm
beginning with their first place sweep
at the april 2018 dreamhack masters in
marseilles in the grand final match-up
against na'vi they've been hunting for
for so long may just joined the roster a
few months ago to try and bring more
firepower into the squad he's certainly
done that
they're looking well-rounded i think
they're in the conversation for the best
team in the world of this performance
they just gonna find that nade it could
take edward down he's on nine health
they're gonna be able to get the bomb
they have enough time to rotate but
they're not gonna go for it it comes
from he's not gonna get the spray on
point but blaze could through the smoke
he's trying to find a way to kill simple
who simply will not fall and i'm going
to be pushing this man and he's got the
kill astronomers are victorious
but this is the main storyline ladies
and gentlemen your champions are
dreamhack masters marseille
it's astralis
[Applause]
including that win astralis proceeded to
win four out of the next seven premier
championships they played in before the
face at london major in september of
2018. there they sprinted to the grand
finals where they would once again
square off with navi in a best-of-three
matchup and once again sweep the team
with ease and you chase after him you
run straight into another one who gets a
free kill you just don't know
and here he is again grenades to follow
up as well
two players left now between astralis
and the first map and they go simple as
well
three kills for device and edward can't
do anything about it either
that is
firmly very firmly taken by australis
simple gets himself a head shot and
that's not the only way in eight seconds
to play though they have to plant the
bomb can't they find their way onto a
plant flamie it's gonna be close but no
one is denied and there's no chance here
in the 1v3 for electronic as australia's
close it down flamey now with the 570's
baiting the play on the short b is red
touching the bomb are going to peak
holding it now and there is it it's just
out of flame it's not going to happen
astralis
[Applause]
a team that is surely a cop above
everybody else every single facet of
their gameplay from practice rooms to
the grand final stage is perfect james
and with that win they became more than
a team that broke their curse they
showed everyone that this was their era
of counter-strike definitely the best
team in the world no argument about that
the preparation
the commitment
the way that this team approached the
game is unrivaled we have not seen this
before in counter-strike history as they
accumulated more and more wins it became
clear they were the new kings of cs go
and they solidified their grip on that
title when they won esl pro league
season 8 and secured the crown jewel of
cs go cash prizes the intel grand slam
nitro has not turned up in this final
map and astralis are so close to this
point one kill's gonna secure it and
that's it
the grand slam is esl broly season 8 as
well
back-to-back ecs back-to-back pro league
marsai
season seven
chicago
and now for the first time ever at home
seems
[Applause]
they accomplished everything a cs team
could dream of in 2018 but it felt like
they didn't even flinch
two majors wasn't good enough for this
team they were poised to drive the final
nail into the coffin of all their haters
first by winning iem katowice and
becoming the second team in cs go
history to claim three majors surely
2019 can't possibly be as good as 2018
but there's no signs of them slowing
down not for dupree either he'll get two
and walk in the smoke glaive he'll only
punish one but it's just ariel will find
and it's done
[Applause]
they had one goal that's it that's all
they wanted back to back and they've
done it now but you can't mess with
greatness you can't mess with history
and these guys are writing it at every
event intel extreme masters champions
majors back-to-back australis again
[Applause]
at katowice dupree whose father had
passed away just days before was
overtaken with emotion by the magnitude
of what he and his teammates had
accomplished
thank you very much alex it's an
emotional stage right now i'm with
dupreeh who i can see has got tears in
his eyes
emotionally for you right now used to be
going through absolutely everything
yeah it's uh it's very unreal um i came
into this tournament with my father
yeah he passed away just before i got
here and his last wish was that i
i went here and so i really want to
dedicate this win to my father
mate come on
and then at starladder berlin in 2019
they made a statement that will echo in
the catacombs of counter-strike history
for years to come
and he doesn't know where to look
doesn't know what to pay attention to
this shot and he's gone and astralis
delivering the final uppercut
to knock out avangar
you can't miss anything if you want to
even have a chance here sanji rushing up
through upper dom dupree is ready to
take him down and now there's no more
retake from that side it's buster and
adren two versus four an impossible
retake by any standard device will take
down buster leaving a trend in upon
versus four and ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
in a row
they have just re-established dominance
forget the hiccup that was team liquid
astralis seems back in a big way
ladies and gentlemen give it up once
again for your champions astronauts
they won their fourth major three of
them in a row and became the most
decorated team of all time the single
greatest counter-strike roster to ever
live
yet despite their success the latter
part of 2019 wasn't all sunshine and
roses for astralis first team liquid
stole a bit of astralis's spotlight with
their runaway win of the intel grand
slam in record time the org was also
accused of having a conflict of interest
with tournament organizer blast
allegations were made that astralis was
showing favoritism towards blast
competitions by choosing to selectively
attend blast events over others refresh
entertainment is a privately held danish
company that manages and operates the
best cs go team in the world that's
astralis they also own and operate the
blast pro series of events now so far
this year astralis have been to all two
blast events and they've skipped out on
three premier tournaments that are not
blast now this has prompted a social
media conversation along these lines is
this a conflict of interest and what
bearing might it have on the future of
competitive cs go the community were
beginning to become critical of the
straws for picking and choosing the
events they'd attend but that sentiment
quickly dissolved as covet 19 ousted
lands for the foreseeable future the now
called online era had started and during
this time both glaive and zip x took
time off due to burnout and stress for
months speculation brewed over whether
the two were gone for good or if
astralis was going to break up but both
had returned to the game by october but
i know that clave was saying how he had
some time away and now he feels like
really fired up while astralis had spent
much of the year utilizing sub and
players like essetag and yugi in place
of its regulars it wasn't particularly
unusual for them for a while the team
often had a sixth man on call a tactic
that has since been heavily employed
during the pandemic by other teams that
faced similar issues indeed it's been
the storyline of the day are we going to
see those mid-match substitutions coming
out from vitality and indeed we are
misuta it's going to be coming out
rivera is going to be coming in next for
dusty astralis fans held out hope that
this was simply a reality of cheering
for the org they'd been committed to
taking their foot off the gas to allow
their players breaks but surely when
land's returned the five danes would be
back competing for an unprecedented
fifth major
or so we all
thought and this is the case ladies and
gentlemen nip have completed uh the
device signing so it's resplobski hamper
ctr and device who thought that was ever
going to happen i don't know really
where we start right now striker do we
talk about like the fallout of like what
this means
in the scheme of things what what are we
we kind of got to let this soak in for a
second
exactly like i feel like we need like
40 minutes just to
kind of like let this
down on me i guess i still feel like i'm
dreaming i have no idea why this
happened
the era of astralis as we knew it
was over since the announcement device's
former teammates have said that they
understand his decision but admitted
that they were caught off guard by it
the first thing i said to him was that
it's okay i understand i think that's
what i said to him the way he presented
it
but then afterwards i was i was
obviously shocked and i was like what is
actually going on it's sad obviously
we've been
i've been disappointed sad angry
both with the virus and the whole
situation even though there are some
things that i don't understand maybe we
could have worked it out
we have still been through so much that
it doesn't change my my view on him as a
person uh he will still be a dear dear
friend of the team for years device had
served as not only an incredible in-game
asset but also a beacon of clarity hope
and optimism for the team he was the
glue that held things together and
tearing that band-aid off has been
painful for what's now left of astralis
it will be hard for slave to
to create a new system it will require
that the pre-making subtext is is also
on board on this and then i think they
can do it they need to like
don't go into this oh it always work
with device these these things they need
to reset and like build it up from zero
again that's my guess because device was
yeah was pretty much the best player in
the world for for three or four years in
my opinion despite some lightly hurt
feelings astralis have been loud in
their support and appreciation for
device and everything he has contributed
to the team uh well obviously nikolai i
know that you have
you have made up your decision and
i respect you fully and i'm i'm gonna
start crying now because it's actually
quite emotional
um how do you put it out i mean i
respect everything you've done and what
we've been through
and yeah i mean i wish you the best
going forward i'm gonna try and do my
best to fulfill your shoes um
but we'll see where everything is goes
from there and
i hope we'll see you at other events and
we've already talked about this and i
appreciate everything
with the vice gone a gaping hole has
been left in astralis not just because
the world's greatest cs go team lost its
star player but also because he was the
team's leader and guiding light during
its darkest hours all of that aside
astralis doesn't actually have to prove
anything to anyone they've already done
what no other team could do four major
wins the first intel grand slam even if
they disband next month or simply never
secure another major again
they're already the greatest of all time
counter-strike is a beautiful timeless
game and what these five danes did will
echo through the minds of every new
generation of fraggers for years to come
and no matter what the future holds
everyone will know that astralis truly
shot to the stars
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]